خمسه ايام دمويه عاشها السودان والافق لا
يزال مسدودا امام الحرب بين القوتين
العسكريتين
الممسكتين بزمام البلاد الاشتباكات تحولت
الى حرب مدن مفتوحه وفيما الحسم
رهن بالايام المقبله يواصل الطرفان
عمليتهما الجيش اعلن عن استعاده مطار مروي
وسلاح المهندسين ومنشات حول مقر القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم حيث ما
تزال قوات الدعم موجوده هناك قوات حمايه
فشلت بتحييد القواعد الجويه والمطارات
الاساسيه في البلاد خلافا لخطتها الاساسيه
فبعد اقتحامها لمطار مروي شمال السودان
واعلانها السيطره عليه عاد الاخير لقبضه
الجيش السوداني واقتصرت مكاسبها جويا على
قاعده جبل اولياء جنوب العاصمه اضافه الى
مطاري في دارفور هما مطار الفاشر شمالا
ومطار صبيره الدولي غربا فشل قوات الدعم
السريع بالسيطره على كافه القواعد الجويه
مكن الجيش من استخدام مقاتلاته لاستهداف
تمركزات وسيارات الدعم السريع بالعاصمه
تحديدا وهي اليات غير مدرعه وهي سهله
التدبير كما ما هذا استخدام سلاح الجو
الطريق امام الجيش للسيطره على مقرات
رئيسيه لقوات الدعم السريع في محيط
العاصمه
كمعسكرات سوبا جنوب خرطوم في الطيبه
والطيبه في شمالها والصالحه ايضا وكرري في
ام درمان كما نشاهد وضمنت كذلك عدم تمكن
الدعم السريع من الحفاظ على مقراتها التي
تحتوي على احتياطيات لوجستيا في ولايتي
النيل الازرق والنيل الابيض وبورسودان
والقضارف وكسله اما النجاحات قوات الدعم
السريع فتتمثل بقطع التواصل بين شمال
العاصمه وايضا جنوبها من خلال سيطرتها على
الجسور وتعطيل حركه المرور لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات